you
are that is a police officer's hat a
member of the NYPD once the most
respected Police Department quite
literally in the world stolen from him
lit on fire and then a guy dressed like
a cobra Soldier and Cobra were the bad
guys in gi. Joe then brought it out to
the middle of the street and dropped it
there and then of course all the you
know the mob of reporters and reporters
I don't know what they are these people
that just come around and film
everything this is a good lit Miss test
for New York City and for Eric Adams and
the New York Police Department if you
cannot at least arrest that guy then if
you are a San person you must leave New
York City now